[Music]
before i've tried basketball
i tried football
really i just i felt better with an axe
in my hand
at southern illinois i had the
opportunity to become a lumberjack
contestants ready
three two one
my name is jack curley i'm the president
of the southern illinois university
forestry club here you go ladies you got
you got it what's going on girl let's go
we're at the 64th midwest forestry
conclave in hillsville missouri put on
by mizzou university
this year i believe there's 11 or 12
schools competing throughout the midwest
here at the conclave
some of the events going on here are the
underhand chop
single buck
single sawing double sawing
jack jack saw jack jill saw bolt toss
we also do events like tree id and wood
id
and traverse where we have to use
coordinates and forestry measurements to
find our way through the woods you know
i'm lucky if i'm still
standing when i'm done
all the events that we do they all come
from traditional forestry skills so this
is our way of keeping all those skills
alive
forestry i always like to think about
the old greek proverb
society grows great when men plant trees
whose shade they'll never sit in and
that really speaks to me when it comes
to forage because in forestry we're
working very long term scales i'm going
to maybe put fourth management plans
that can affect my kids and my you know
grandkids and so if i put in a trail i
want to make sure that trail is done
right if we're going to cut timber i
want to make trees get planted
afterwards you know it's a very long
term process
when you're out there announcer says
your name over the speakers
and the whole team just cheers your
family screaming and you can't do
anything but smile and you just want to
grab the axe and you want to chop the
wood as fast as you can
this is just
you know where i belong
[Music]
you